yeah there is definitely an innate
craving for
attention validation
from people in general or from men
um
in terms of survival
i think that's a complicated one it
varies i suppose
do you guys think
i don't think they need attention to
survive
[Laughter]
maybe a water
but um
i don't think that's a female thing i
feel like people need attention right
there's like a load of people
that need attention and they're just
needy people
yeah i think they needed it
that's why when they hit the wall they
like implode
[Laughter]
absolutely a woman won't go to three
hours to turn yourself up for no
attention that don't make any sense
absolutely yeah they literally evaporate
if they don't get enough attention
so um i have a question for the matt
do you feel like women are more
interested when you give them attention
or not
oh gosh so in the current dating market
i think
it's complicated because a lot of people
are used to toxic relationships so often
from experience what i've seen is
if you do
if there if there are certain women who
are
receiving quite a lot of attention and
on a regular basis you know they're very
attractive what can tend to happen is if
they sense a sense of desperation or you
trying to try too hard
they can tend to pull away but then if
you step back yourself
they can tend to desire more it's almost
like that phenomenon of
people wanting what they can't have
so
yeah it just depends i suppose um women
live for attention
yeah absolutely
they can't get enough of it
and and
i'll give an example i had a friend
i was working from home and she comes
when i was working from home and because
i was working i'm not paying attention
she's turning a tantrum
i don't know what you're not working
from one before you came here i'm not
gonna leave working so they can't get
enough of it it's like i'm petrol in the
car
yeah i actually i posted like a youtube
short about this that's how passionate i
am
and my theory is
that the modern woman is a narcissist
and that they can only bond
via
men's time and attention and that's that
that that theory underpins all your
success in dating
um the reason why you can't talk to them
so much you have to play these games of
attention and status when you text
someone unhinged tinder
is is because of that it's because
it doesn't matter what you say she's not
actually interested in you there's like
20 people that match with her she's what
she's trying to do she's trying to she's
going to fall in love with herself via
the proxy of your time and attention
that's why it's better that she you talk
20 and she talks 80
because she doesn't care what you do
so
that's my theory is that what you put in
your youtube channel yeah i was just
like this is why masculine men don't
talk much it's pointless
like you're insecure yeah
uh only 200 views so far but i'm gonna
get roasted i'm waiting for it you've
been shadow bent
you know it's funny um because i always
hear guys say that like when you give
like when you pull back then like girls
will come at you stronger and harder
would you say that's true absolutely
yeah
i think it i mean generally in terms of
yeah the toxic dating environment that
does tend to be the case but for people
who are stable
which is rarer these days
yeah
um sometimes they're not interested in
playing games they just want a man who's
actually going to have vendors
yeah yeah that's that's for women who
aren't most of them
yeah but that's just toxic in your
experience
the only reason they they chase you back
is because they want the validation so
so that process is just getting them
hooked on the validation do you think
that's the case for every woman yeah
period yeah well well stable woman won't
won't let a conversation be that
one-sided so so there'll be an equal
sense of loss but when you're
mismatching someone a hinge or tinder
yeah you've been making her feel like
the most fascinating sexy woman in the
planet and you've stopped texting after
a while she's going to be like yeah
so what question what games have you
used that worked games yeah that worked
i think i've given up on games i think
probably in my earlier less mature
stages yeah okay
it could be from a while ago it doesn't
mean you're currently doing it okay from
a while ago probably
yeah that you know trying to play it
cool not trying to do too much you know
making sure that you don't do things
like double texting you know making sure
that you're trying to keep that interest
from just you know what the dane gurus
will tell you pull back don't don't give
too much don't don't sound too desperate
play game you know that kind of thing
yeah why because that was before though
but like don't you think that that's the
kind of people you're going to attract
if that's what you're out there doing
and i'm i'm saying i hear that you're
not doing that anymore
but
that was a response to the women though
yeah
that's what i'm saying like man it
wasn't i wanted to just be me but every
time you kind of just be you obviously
you have that phenomenon of she's
texting how many different guys right
that's how that's how it so then you're
trying to
almost compete
but then she's getting it all the time
so the normal
influx of attention attention attention
doesn't it's like when people are
watching corn
you know um generally they get bored of
the thing they've watched yesterday and
then they want to watch something else
so because of the attention span so that
that you know normal span of attention
you're giving isn't being appreciated as
much until you change something about it
to make it more interesting well i don't
i think men like they don't do anything
unless women require it
so like if women if women complain about
men like like playing games or whatever
like men don't do anything that doesn't
work
so it's like if women required that men
take them on like
like 30 dates before they slept with
them men would do it but it's like
when they do that and it doesn't work
then they change what they're doing so
if like a guy's being in this in this
scenario right if a guy's being nice
and giving girls tons of attention and
it's not working they change what
they're doing
so like the state of men is a reflection
of women
i definitely agree with it yep that's
true like men will jump through hoops to
get laid before before the development
of birth control they would literally
marry a girl to get laid
and i've and i've talked to older like
men about this and they're like yeah i
got married so i could get laid
you can literally learn the game from
women as well
so the women women play much more
sophisticated games with each other than
we do so you actually learn about the
meaning of the double text from women
when they talk when she's like oh yeah
stacy wants to come over and she texts
me twice she's like really begging it
that kind of stuff but i had two
strategies right there was one where i
was like me
nerdy i was like yeah i like this anime
yeah you know speaking in his poetry and
whatever not cheesy stuff but like you
know just add a lot of things so that
you can have a conversation from right
if you really want to talk to me i've
given you like 20 things here my
favorite movie my favorite color i've
made a joke here that didn't work so
then i tried the games right short texts
take time in between texts match her
time because women notice this if if you
apply too quickly they notice they think
you're lame
um and then women got super attached
when i did that but there was one girl i
was talking for like a day
and then i took like 15 minutes to add
her number on what's up when she blocked
me and i was like she was investing fam
like
all i did was ask her about her dog i
was like oh does he slobber hahaha sexy
or whatever yeah so
wait till you got blocked well she yeah
she blocked me on whatsapp and um on the
hinge because yeah she gave me a number
is that is that a good sign to get
blocked yeah that's what i mean like are
you sure that's why she blocked you
massively yeah because she showed she
was invested so if you gave me a number
like yeah let's hang out and i i added
and text you the next day and you've
blocked me by then it must have meant
she felt she felt silly because she gave
me a number and i didn't text her for a
while or she blocked you because she was
like [ __ ] i've given this guy my number
and i don't want to like no disrespect
to you but like yeah
[Laughter]
um
with women because they love attention
if you if you say tell me about yourself
i just listen
for the next two hours she can go on but
okay guys do you not think maybe this is
like the women that you're attracting
because you're saying you're looking for
these girls on dating apps but you're
only gonna like i'm not taking all women
on dating apps by the way
but you're you're like you're attracting
a very specific type of woman like
you're not like well i think the point
is women like to talk more than men yeah
so it's just a biological difference
like i don't remember what the
percentage is but we use so many more
words in a day than men
yeah gonna use at least 20 000 words
today compared to seven thousand that
menus
so
where's what's that message though let
the woman talk
on the impact of your words yeah if as a
man if you're always talking you
undermine yourself because people think
you're you're silly firstly people are
always judging you by what you say if i
walk into a room of guys and i'm like ha
ha hey guys i like this that they start
they're watching me thinking this guy's
cheesy